[Music]  it's a new day back to work it will not  be listening to no orcish music that is  one of the greatest love songs ever  written yeah well I feel sorry for work  ladies  [Music]  we had Amnon show us enroute first time  being shot at yeah I just liked it very  much  yeah it sucks  the new killer weapon that grants wishes  I'm assuming this doesn't end well  don't know warrior a priestess a lover  I am whatever my it needs to be this  falls into the wrong hands  the whole world is in danger  it'll teach now the Academy  no they do not gonna put an end to  I thought you were dead I'm had too many  bills to pay  [Music]  I took the little homie out LAPD style  up you do fairy lives don't matter today  [Music]